so you're about to start a family
or you've already started one having a
child is a beautiful transcendent
experience
but you're also going to find yourself
asking how much is this going to cost me
i like him holding up this uh notebook
[Music]
this episode is personal to me bobby
here was born last year
and i often look at him and i wonder
what the future holds
not just for him but for uh me and my
wallet
what does daycare cost what do diapers
cost does he need a college fund
it's pretty daunting to add all that
stuff up but christina livederry has
actually crunched the numbers
christina thank you so much for being on
good money i
just had a baby he's nine months old so
we're kind of going through
this there's figures out there that most
people get
about what having a kid costs
and you kind of delved into that and
uh saw that it saw what the truth was i
suppose
it really does vary and depend upon a
number of factors
so a great cost that can vary a lot
is is the cost of maternity health care
on average americans can expect to spend
if they're covered by a health plan
forty five hundred dollars
for routine maternity health care
that doesn't include you know if you
have an emergency c-section
or if you have a a longer than expected
stay in the nicu
so 4 500 is really just the base
starting point
the next thing we wanted to investigate
was what we call getting ready for baby
costs
how much are we going to spend on
getting that
nursery ready most of our clients spend
about five
thousand dollars for some of those
bigger items
that don't get bought during the baby
shower so that could be your crib
your bassinet your stroller it's worth
mentioning
the baby care products market is
projected to be worth over 100 billion
dollars worldwide by 2025.
you could do parental um
or birthing classes so that's like 650
that's like on average for one of those
classes
but there's also uh doulas and lactation
consultants
on average was about 2500 for
either that lactation consultant and or
doula so then the final part
the most you'll spend on your your child
is child care
the cost of child care is enormous
very early on if you decide and you have
the means to do
a night nurse that night nurse in la can
range anywhere from thirty dollars to
forty dollars an
hour and then you also have just basic
child care so whether it's
infant daycare a nanny and
especially popular here in los angeles
is
having an au pair and so an au pair will
cost you
20 000 a year but the other thing is
that they'll also
have to live with you so if you add all
those up it comes to a grand total of
forty seven thousand dollars
whoo yeah gosh
that's the cost of having a baby right
now but what about the future
are they going to go to college trade
school when are they going to move out
of the house
ever roger ma is a certified financial
planner and he's been thinking about
this stuff a lot
especially since he has a baby of his
own name owen both of them joined us
to talk
let me just start by saying uh i i
haven't done anything to prepare for
bobby's financial future
i'm starting at zero what can i do today
to to make that a rosier picture it's
always good to get a sense of where
you're starting from so
i think coming up with your financial
report card
which includes calculating your net
worth
figuring out what your living expenses
are how much you spend on a monthly
basis yeah owen
and in what categories and then also
what your credit score is as well
and i think that's a great starting
point
is saving for college as big of a deal
now as it
used to be the cost of education has
been
increasing substantially year
after year but honestly i don't think we
really know
what the what form higher education is
going to take
in 15 20 years um
and if it's gonna be as important in
terms of uh
employers using it for signaling so i
certainly recommend
to save within a 529 plan a 529 plan is
a tax advantage
savings account designed to be used for
a beneficiary's education expenses
like bobby's let's say
uh i i do a 529 plan and uh
he grows up and he's like i don't want
to go to college
um what happens to that money yeah so um
usually
if you're taking it out for non-eligible
expenses
you might get taxed at your uh federal
tax rate
um state tax might be subject to local
tax too
and then you might pay a penalty as well
that said i think it's also important
to save within say a roth ira or a
taxable brokerage account
money in those accounts is a little more
flexible than
money in a 529 plan our education
expenses
what does that include so i believe it
includes room board
tuition uh certain electronic expenses
like computer
and some other technology there's some
flexibility to change the beneficiary in
the account so certainly
you might intend to use it for bobby's
educational expenses but let's say he
goes to college you still have money
left
and you want to take a a class for
yourself
and it's at an eligible institution you
could change the beneficiary to yourself
i think the other two things um that
would be
helpful to get in a place are
a term life insurance policy outside of
your
employer coverage and then making sure
that you have an estate plan
in place and if you already have one in
place
updating it to incorporate your little
one
and particularly not only
figuring out where your stuff goes but
in the case where you're not around and
your partner
isn't around who is going to take care
of bobby
so start a 529 plan get a term life
insurance policy outside of my employer
and change my estate planner will
to include bobby
alright so i'm starting to feel better
now that i know the cost it's probably
going to be in the
tens of thousands of dollars this is
information that i wish i'd had
a while ago and that i hope that
he has someday as well unfortunately
he's probably not going to learn this in
our traditional school system
the best example is going to be learning
from you
how does one teach kids to have a good
relationship with money
even if you don't feel like you have a
great relationship with money you have a
good understanding of your own money
situation i'm sharing your
money ideas and any experiences with
money
money is in every facet of our life
going to the grocery store
driving our cars living in our houses so
being
open and honest with our children when
you're making a grocery list
and going and looking at the ads to see
what's on sale this week
when you're talking about doing chores
in the house if you're going to give an
allowance and
why we would be doing that for our
children like why we're giving you
the allowance and just leading by
example and not being
afraid of your own insecurities around
money because
those are going to transpose onto your
children what would you suggest
is like a proper amount to divulge about
you know income um comfort
just being more open even if it's like
possibly
negative things telling your kids we
don't have enough money for that or
remember we want to go
and take this vacation next month so
this month we're not going to go out to
dinner or we're not going to go to
um chuck e cheese or to the movies we're
going to try to save our money because
we want to have money for next
our next trip our next month and just
explaining
that process to children what's actually
going on in your head i think is very
helpful because
a lot of times they don't see it they
don't understand how the money even
comes in
why daddy goes to work why mommy goes to
work um
that putting gas in the car costs money
sometimes they don't even see those
transactions
um so allowing them to see those
transactions is always
very um helpful
so we talked about expenses planning and
teaching your kids about money
now i hope that the school system starts
to make financial education a little bit
more commonplace
but until then we're gonna have to just
do it ourselves
you